PROFESSOR: All right,
everyone, so we
are very happy to have Andy Beck
as our invited speaker today.
Andy has a very
unique background.
He's trained both as a computer
scientist and as a clinician.
His specialty is in pathology.
When he was a
student at Stanford,
his thesis was on how one could
use machine learning algorithms
to really understand a
pathology data set, at the time,
using more traditional
regression-style approaches
to understanding
what the field is now
called computational pathology.
But his work was really at
the forefront of his field.
Since then, he's
come to Boston, where
he was an attending and faculty
at Beth Israel Deaconess
Medical Center.
In the recent couple
of years, he's
been running a
company called PathAI,
which is, in my opinion, one
of the most exciting companies
of AI in medicine.
And he is my favorite
invited speaker--
ANDY BECK: He says
that to everyone.
PROFESSOR: --every time I get
an opportunity to invite someone
to speak.
And I think you'll be
really interested in what
he has to say.
ANDY BECK: Great.
Well, thank you so much.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah, I'm really excited
to talk in this course.
It is a super exciting time for
machine learning in pathology
And if you have any
questions throughout,
please feel free to ask.
And so for some background
on what pathology is--
it's so like, if
you're a patient.
You go to the
doctor, and AI could
apply in any aspect of
this whole trajectory,
and I'll kind of talk about
specifically in pathology.
So you go to the doctor.
They take a bunch
of data from you.
You talk to them.
They get signs and symptoms.
Typically, if they're
at all concerned,
and it could be something that's
a structural alteration that's
not accessible just
through taking blood work,
say, like a cancer, which is
one of the biggest things,
they'll send you to radiology
where they want to--
the radiology is the best
way for acquiring data
to look for big
structural changes.
So you can't see single
cells in radiology.
But you can see inside the body
and see some large things that
are changing to make
evaluations for,
like, you have a cough, like
are you looking at lung cancer,
or are you looking at pneumonia?
And radiology only
takes you so far.
And people are super excited
about applying AI to radiology,
but I think one thing
they often forget
is these images are not
very data-rich compared
to the core data types.
I mean, this is my
bias from pathology,
but radiology gets you
some part of the way,
where you can sort of
triage normal stuff.
And the radiologist will
have some impression
of what they're looking at.
And often, that's
the bottom line
in the radiology report
is impression-- concerning
for cancer, or impression--
likely benign but not sure,
or impression-- totally benign.
And that will also guide
subsequent decisions.
But if there's some concern that
something serious is going on,
the patient undergoes a
pretty serious procedure,
which is a tissue biopsy.
So pathology
requires tissue to do
what I'm going to
talk about, which
is surgical pathology that
requires tissue specimen.
There's also blood-based things.
But then this is the diagnosis
where you're trying to say
is this cancer?
Is this not cancer?
And that report by
itself can really
guide subsequent
decisions, which
could be no further
treatment or a big surgery
or a big decision about
chemotherapy and radiotherapy.
So this is one area
where you really
want to incorporate data
in the most effective way
to reduce errors, to
increase standardization,
and to really inform
the best treatment
decision for each patient
based on the characteristics
of their disease.
And the one thing
about pathology
that's pretty interesting
is it's super visual.
And this is just a
kind of random sampling
of some of the types
of different imagery
that pathologists are
looking at every day.
I think this is one thing that
draws people to this specialty
is a saying in
radiology, you're sort
of looking at an impression of
what might be happening based
on sending different
types of images
and acquiring the data
and sort of trying
to estimate what's going on.
Whereas here, you're actually
staining pieces of tissue
and looking by eye at
actual individual cells.
You can look within cells.
You can look at how populations
of cells are being organized.
And for many diseases,
this still represents
sort of the core data type
that defines what's going on,
and is this something with
a serious prognosis that
requires, say, surgery?
Or is this something
that's totally benign?
All of these are different
aspects of benign processes.
And so just the
normal human body
creates all these
different patterns.
And then there's a lot
of patterns of disease.
And these are all different
subtypes of disease that
are all different morphologies.
So there's sort of
an incredible wealth
of different visual imagery
that the pathologist
has to incorporate
into their diagnosis.
And then there's,
on top of that,
things like special
stains that can
stain for specific organisms,
for infectious disease,
or specific patterns
of protein expression,
for subtyping disease based
on expression of drug targets.
And this even more sort of
increases the complexity
of the work.
So for many years,
there's really nothing new
about trying to apply
AI or machine learning
or computation to this field.
It's actually a
very natural field,
because it's sort
of laboratory-based.
It's all about data processing.
You take this input,
things like images,
and produces output,
what a diagnosis is.
So people have really been
trying this for 40 years
or so now.
This is one of the very first
studies that sort of just
tried to see, could
we train a computer
to identify the
size of cancer cells
through a process they
called morphometry, here
on the bottom?
And then could we just
use sort of measurements
about the size of cancer
cells in a very simple model
to predict outcome?
And in this study,
they have a learning
set that they're learning
from and then a test set.
And they show that their
system, as every paper that
ever gets published shows, does
better than the two competing
approaches.
Although even in this
best case scenario,
there's significant degradation
from learning to test.
So one, it's super simple.
It's using very simple
methods, and the data sets
are tiny, 38 learning
cases, 40 test cases.
And this is published in The
Lancet, which is the leading
biomedical journal even today.
And then people got
excited about AI
sort of building off
of simple approaches.
And back in 1990, it was thought
artificial neural nets would
be super useful for
quantitative pathology
for sort of obvious reasons.
But at that time,
there was really
no way of digitizing stuff
at any sort of scale,
and that problem's only
recently been solved.
But sort of in 2000, people
were first thinking about
once the slides
are digital, then
you could apply computational
methods effectively.
But kind of nothing
really changed,
and still, to a
large degree, hasn't
changed for the
predominance of pathology,
which I'll talk about.
But as was mentioned
earlier, I was
part of one of the first studies
to really take a more machine
learning approach to this.
And what we mean
by machine learning
versus prior
approaches is the idea
of using data-driven analysis
to figure out the best features.
And now you can do that in
an even more explicit way
with machine
learning, but there's
sort of a progression
from measuring one or two
things in a very tedious way
on very small data sets to,
I'd say, this way,
where we're using
some traditional
regression-based machine
learning to measure larger
numbers of features.
And then using things
like those associations,
those features with
patient outcome
to focus your analyses on
the most important ones.
And the challenging
machine learning task here
and really one of the
core tasks in pathology
is image processing.
So how do we train
computers to sort of
have the knowledge
of what is being
looked at that any pathologist
would want to have?
And there's a few
basic things you'd
want to train the
computer to do,
which is, for example,
identify where's the cancer?
Where's the stroma?
Where are the cancer cells?
Where are the
fibroblasts, et cetera?
And then once you train a
machine learning based system
to identify those
things, you can then
extract lots of quantitative
phenotypes out of the images.
And this is all using
human-engineered features
to measure all the different
characteristics of what's
going on in an image.
And machine learning
is being used here
to create those features.
And then we use other
regression-based methods
to associate these features with
things like clinical outcome.
And in this work, we
show that by taking
a data-driven
approach, sort of, you
begin to focus on
things like what's
happening in the tumor
microenvironment,
not just in the tumor itself?
And it sort of turned
out, over the past decade,
that understanding the way the
tumor interacts with the tumor
microenvironment is sort of one
of the most important things
to do in cancer with
things like fields
like immunooncology
being one of the biggest
advances in the
therapy of cancer,
where you're essentially
just regulating
how tumor cells interact
with the cells around them.
And that sort of data
is entirely inaccessible
using traditional
pathology approaches
and really required a
machine learning approach
to extract a bunch of features
and sort of let the data speak
for itself in terms of
which of those features
is most important for survival.
And in this study, we
showed that these things
are associated with survival.
I don't know if
you guys do a lot
of Kaplan-Meier plots in here.
PROFESSOR: They saw it once,
but taking us through it
slowly is never a bad idea.
ANDY BECK: Yeah, so these are--
I feel there's one
type of plot to know
for most of biomedical research,
and it's probably this one.
And it's extremely simple.
So it's really just an
empirical distribution
of how patients are
doing over time.
So the x-axis is time.
And here, the goal is to
build a prognostic model.
I wish I had a
predictive one in here,
but we can talk about
what that would look like.
But a prognostic model,
any sort of prognostic test
in any disease in
medicine is to try
to create subgroups that show
different survival outcomes.
And then by implication,
they may benefit
from different therapies.
They may not.
That doesn't answer
that question,
but it just tells
you if you want
to make an estimate for
how a patient's going
to be doing in five years,
and you can sub-classify them
into two groups, this is
a way to visualize it.
You don't need two groups.
You could do this
with even one group,
but it's frequently used to show
differences between two groups.
So you'll see here, there's
a black line and a red line.
And these are groups
of patients where
a model trained
not on these cases
was trained to separate
high-risk patients
from low-risk patients.
And the way we did that was
we did logistic regression
on a different data set, sort
of trying to classify patients
alive at five years following
diagnosis versus patients
deceased, five years diagnosis.
We build a model.
We fix the model.
Then we apply it to this
data set of about 250 cases.
And then we just ask, did we
actually effectively create
two different groups of patients
whose survival distribution is
significantly different?
So what this p-value
is telling you
is the probability that
these two curves come
from the same
underlying distribution
or that there's no difference
between these two curves
across all of the time points.
And what we see
here is there seems
to be a difference between the
black line versus the red line,
where, say, 10 years, the
probability of survival
is about 80% in the low-risk
group and more like 60%
in the high-risk group.
And overall, the
p-value's very small
for there being a difference
between those two curves.
So that's sort of like
what a successful type
Kaplan-Meier plot would
look like if you're
trying to create a model
that separates patients
into groups with different
survival distributions
And then it's always important
for these types of things
to try them on
multiple data sets.
And here we show the same model
applied to a different data set
showed pretty similar overall
effectiveness at stratifying
patients into two groups.
So why do you think doing
this might be useful?
I guess, yeah, anyone?
Because there's actually,
I think this type of curve
is often confused with one that
actually is extremely useful,
which I would say-- yeah?
PROFESSOR: Why don't you wait?
ANDY BECK: Sure.
PROFESSOR: Don't be shy.
You can call them.
ANDY BECK: All right.
AUDIENCE: Probably
you can you use
this to start off
when the patient's
of high-risk and
probably at five years,
if the patient has high-risk,
probably do a follow-up.
ANDY BECK: Right, exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
So that would be a great use.
PROFESSOR: Can you repeat the
question for the recording?
ANDY BECK: So it was
saying like if you
know someone's at a high
risk of having an event prior
to five years, an event is
when the curve goes down.
So definitely, the red group
is at 40, almost double
or something the risk
of the black group.
So if you have
certain interventions
you can do to help prevent
these things, such as giving
an additional treatment or
giving more frequent monitoring
for recurrence.
Like if you can do a follow-up
scan in a month versus six
months, you could make that
decision in a data-driven way
by knowing whether the
patient's on the red curve
or the black curve.
So yeah, exactly right.
It helps you to make therapeutic
decisions when there's
a bunch of things you
can do, either give
more aggressive treatment or
do more aggressive monitoring
of disease, depending on
is it aggressive disease
or a non-aggressive disease.
The other type of curve
that I think often
gets confused with
these that's quite
useful is one that directly
tests that intervention.
So essentially, you
could do a trial
of the usefulness, the clinical
utility of this algorithm,
where on the one hand, you
make the prediction on everyone
and don't do
anything differently.
And then the other one
is you make a prediction
on the patients,
and you actually
use it to make a decision, like
more frequent treatment or more
frequent intervention.
And then you could
do a curve, saying
among the high-risk patients,
where we actually acted on it,
that's black.
And if we didn't
act on it, it's red.
And then, if you do the
experiment in the right way,
you can make the inference
that you're actually
preventing death by 50%
if the intervention is
causing black versus red.
Here, we're not doing
anything with causality.
We're just sort of observing
how patients do differently
over time.
But frequently, you see these
as the figure, the key figure
for a randomized
control trial, where
the only thing different
between the groups of patients
is the intervention.
And that really lets you
make a powerful inference
that changes what
care should be.
This one, you're just like, OK,
maybe we should do something
differently, but
not really sure,
but it makes intuitive sense.
But if you actually
have something
from a randomized clinical
trial or something else
that allows you to
infer causality,
this is the most
important figure.
And you can actually infer
how many lives are being saved
or things by doing something.
But this one's not
about intervention.
It's just about
sort of observing
how patients do over time.
So that was some of the
work from eight years ago,
and none of this has
really changed in practice.
Everyone is still using
glass slides and microscopes
in the clinic.
Research is a totally
different story.
But still, 99% of
clinic is using
these old-fashioned
technologies-- microscopes
from technology breakthroughs
in the mid-1800s, staining
breakthroughs in the late 1800s.
The H and E stain
is the key stain.
So aspects of pathology
haven't moved forward at all,
and this has pretty
significant consequences.
And here's just
a couple of types
of figures that really
allow you to see
the primary data for what
a problem interobserver
variability really is
in clinical practice.
And this is just
another, I think,
really nice, empirical
way of viewing raw data,
where there is a ground
truth consensus of experts,
who sort of decided what all
these 70 or so cases were,
through experts always
knowing the right answer.
And for all of these
70, called them
all the category
of atypia, which
here is indicated in yellow.
And then they took
all of these 70 cases
that the experts that
are atypia and sent them
to hundreds of pathologists
across the country
and for each one, just
plotted the distribution
of different diagnoses
they were receiving.
And quite strikingly-- and
this was published in JAMA,
a great journal, about
four years ago now--
they show this
incredible distribution
of different diagnoses
among each case.
So this is really
why you might want
a computational approach is
there should be the same color.
This should just be one big
color or maybe a few outliers,
but for almost any case,
there's a significant proportion
of people calling it
normal, which is yellow--
or sorry, tan, then
atypical, which is yellow,
and then actually cancer,
which is orange or red.
PROFESSOR: What
does atypical mean?
ANDY BECK: Yeah, so atypical
is this border area between
totally normal and cancer,
where the pathologist is saying
it's--
which is actually the
most important diagnosis
because totally
normal you do nothing.
Cancer-- there's well-described
protocols for what to do.
Atypia, they often overtreat.
And that's sort of
the bias in medicine
is always assume the worst when
you get a certain diagnosis
back.
So atypia has nuclear features
of cancer but doesn't fully.
You know, maybe you get
7 of the 10 criteria
or three of the five criteria.
And it has to do
with sort of nuclei
looking a little bigger and a
little weirder than expected
but not enough where the
pathologist feels comfortable
calling it cancer.
And that's part of
the reason that that
shows almost a coin flip.
Of the ones the experts
called atypia, only 48%
was agreed with
in the community.
The other interesting thing the
study showed was intraobserver
variability is just as big
of an issue as interobserver.
So a person disagrees with
themselves after an eight month
washout period
pretty much as often
as they disagree with others.
So another reason why
computational approaches
would be valuable and why
this really is a problem.
And this is in breast biopsies.
The same research group
showed quite similar results.
This was in British Medical
Journal in skin biopsies, which
is another super important
area, where, again they
have the same type of
visualization of data.
They have five different classes
of severity of skin lesions,
ranging from a totally
normal benign nevus, like I'm
sure many of us have on
our skin to a melanoma,
which is a serious, malignant
cancer that needs to be treated
as soon as possible.
And here, the white
color is totally benign.
The darker blue
color is melanoma.
And again, they show lots of
discordance, pretty much as
bad as in the breast biopsies.
And here again, the
intraobserver variability
with an eight-month washout
period was about 33%.
So people disagree
with themselves
one out of three times.
And then these aren't totally
outlier cases or one research
group.
The College of
American Pathologists
did a big summary of 116
studies and showed overall,
an 18.3% median discrepancy
rate across all the studies
and a 6% major
discrepancy rate, which
would be a major
clinical decision
is the wrong one, like
surgery, no surgery, et cetera.
And those sort of
in the ballpark
agree with the previously
published findings.
So a lot of reasons
to be pessimistic
but one reason to be very
optimistic is the one area
where AI is not-- not the one
area, but maybe one of two
or three areas where AI is
not total hype is vision.
Vision really started working
well as, I don't if you've
covered in this class but with
deep convolutional neural nets
in 2012.
And then all the
groups sort of just
kept getting incrementally
better year over year.
And now this is an
old graph from 2015,
but there's been a huge
development of methods
even since 2015, where
now I think we really
understand the strengths and the
weaknesses of these approaches.
And pathology sort of has
a lot of the strengths,
which is super well-defined,
very focused questions.
And I think there's lots of
failures whenever you try
to do anything more general.
But for the types of tasks where
you know exactly what you're
looking for and you can
generate the training data,
these systems can
work really well.
So that's a lot of what
we're focused on at PathAI
is how do we extract
the most information out
of pathology images
really doing two things.
One is understanding
what's inside the images
and the second is using deep
learning to sort of directly
try to infer patient
level phenotypes
and outcomes directly
from the images.
And we use both
traditional machine
learning models
for certain things,
like particularly
making inference
at the patient level, where
n is often very small.
But anything that's directly
operating on the image
is almost some variant always of
deep convolutional neural nets,
which really are the state of
the art for image processing.
And we sort of, a lot of what
we think about at PathAI,
and I think what's really
important in this area of ML
for medicine is generating
the right data set
and then using things
like deep learning
to optimize all of the
features in a data-driven away,
and then really
thinking about how
to use the outputs
of these models
intelligently and really
validate them in a robust way,
because there's many
ways to be fooled
by artefacts and other things.
So just some of the--
not to belabor the points, but
why these approaches are really
valuable in this
application is it allows you
to exhaustively analyze slides.
So a pathologist,
the reason they're
making so many errors is they're
just kind of overwhelmed.
I mean, there's two reasons.
One is humans aren't good at
interpreting visual patterns.
Actually, I think that's not
the real reason, because humans
are pretty darn good at that.
And there are difficult
things where we can disagree,
but when people focus on small
images, frequently they agree.
But these images are
enormous, and humans just
don't have enough time to
study carefully every cell
on every slide.
Whereas, the computer,
in a real way,
can be forced to
exhaustively analyze
every cell on every slide, and
that's just a huge difference.
It's quantitative.
I mean, this is one thing
the computer is definitely
better at.
It can compute huge
numerators, huge denominators,
and exactly compute proportions.
Whereas, when a person
is looking at a slide,
they're really just eyeballing
some percentage based
on a very small amount of data.
It's super efficient.
So you can analyze--
this whole process is
massively paralyzable,
so you can almost
do a slide as fast
as you want based on how much
you're willing to spend on it.
And it allows you not only
do all of of these, sort of,
automation tasks exhaustively,
quantitatively, and efficiently
but also discover a lot of new
insights from the data, which
I think we did in
a very early way,
back eight years ago,
when we sort of had
human-extracted features
correlate those with outcome.
But now you can really
supervise the whole process
with machine learning
of how you go
from the components of an
image to patient outcomes
and learn new biology that
you didn't know going in.
And everyone's
always like, well,
are you just going to
replace pathologists?
And I really don't think this
is, in any way, the future.
In almost every field that's
sort of like where automation
is becoming very
common, the demand
for people who are experts
in that area is increasing.
And like airplane
pilots is one I was just
learning about today.
They just do a completely
different thing
than they did 20 years
ago, and now it's
all about mission control
of this big system
and understanding all the
flight management systems
and understanding all
the data they're getting.
And I think the job has not
gotten necessarily simpler,
but they're much more
effective, and they're doing
much different types of work.
And I do think
the pathologist is
going to move from
sort of staring
into a microscope with a
literally very myopic focus
on very small
things to being more
of a consultant with
physicians, integrating lots
of different types
of data, things
that AI is really bad
at, a lot of reasoning
about specific instances,
and then providing
that guidance to physicians.
So I think the job will
look a lot different,
but we never really needed more
diagnosticians in the future
than in the past.
So one example, I think
we sent out a reading
about this was this concept
of breast cancer metastasis
is a good use case
of machine learning.
And this is just
a patient example.
So a primary mass is discovered.
So one of the big
determinants of the prognosis
from a primary tumor is has
it spread to the lymph nodes?
Because that's one
of the first areas
that tumors metastasize to.
And the way to diagnose whether
tumors have metastasized
to lymph nodes is
to take a biopsy
and then evaluate those
for the presence of cancer
where it shouldn't be.
And this is a task that's very
quantitative and very tedious.
So the International Symposium
on Biomedical Imaging
organized this challenge called
the Chameleon 16 Challenge,
where they put together almost
300 training slides and about
130 test slides.
And they asked a bunch of teams
to build machine learning based
systems to automate the
evaluation of the test
slides, both to diagnose whether
the slide contained cancer
or not, as well as to actually
identify where in the slides
the cancer was located.
And kind of the big machine
learning challenge here,
why you can't just throw
it into a off-the-shelf
or on the web image
classification tool
is the images are so
large that it's just not
feasible to throw
the whole image
into any kind of neural net.
Because they can be
between 20,000 and 200,000
pixels on a side.
So they have millions of pixels.
And for that, we do
this process where
we start with a
labeled data set,
where there are these very
large regions labeled either
as normal or tumor.
And then we build
procedures, which is actually
a key component of getting
machine learning to work well,
of sampling patches of images
and putting those patches
into the model.
And this sampling
procedure is actually
incredibly important
for controlling
the behavior of the
system, because you could
sample in all different ways.
You're never going to
sample exhaustively
just because there's far
too many possible patches.
So thinking about the right
examples to show the system
has an enormous effect
on both the performance
and the generalizability of
the systems you're building.
And some of the, sort
of, insights we learned
was how best to do
the, sort of, sampling.
But once you have these samples,
it's all data driven-- sure.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk more
about the sampling strategy
schemes?
ANDY BECK: Yeah, so
from a high level,
you want to go from
random sampling, which
is a reasonable thing to do,
to more intelligent sampling,
based on knowing what
the computer needs
to learn more about.
And one thing we've done and--
so it's sort of like
figuring-- so the first step is
sort of simple.
You can randomly sample.
But then the second
part is a little harder
to figure out what
examples do you
want to enrich your
training set for to make
the system perform even better?
And there's different things
you can optimize for, for that.
So it's sort of like this
whole sampling actually
being part of the
machine learning
procedure is quite useful.
And you're not just going
to be sampling once.
You could iterate on
this and keep providing
different types of samples.
So for example, if
you learn that it's
missing certain types
of errors, or it
hasn't seen enough of certain--
there's many ways
of getting at it.
But if you know it hasn't
seen enough types of examples
in your training set, you
can over-sample for that.
Or if you see you have
a confusion matrix
and you see it's failing
on certain types,
you can try to figure out
why is it failing on those
and alter the sampling
procedure to enrich for that.
You could even provide
outputs to humans,
who can point you to the areas
where it's making mistakes.
Because often you don't
have exhaustively labeled.
In this case, we actually
did have exhaustively labeled
slides.
So it was somewhat easier.
But you can see there's
even a lot of heterogeneity
within the different classes.
So you might do some
clever tricks to figure out
what are the types of the red
class that it's getting wrong,
and how am I going to fix that
by providing it more examples?
So I think, sort of, that's
one of the easier things
to control.
Rather than trying to
tune other parameters
within these super complicated
networks, in our experience,
just playing with the
training, the sampling
piece of the training,
it should almost just
be thought of as
another parameter
to optimize for when you're
dealing with a problem
where you have humongous
slides and you can't
use all the training data.
AUDIENCE: So decades ago,
I met some pathologists
who were looking at
cervical cancer screening.
And they thought that you
could detect a gradient
in the degree of atypia.
And so not at training time
but at testing time, what
they were trying to do was to
follow that gradient in order
to find the most atypical
part of of the image.
Is that still
believed to be true?
ANDY BECK: Yeah.
That it's a continuum?
Yeah, definitely.
PROFESSOR: You mean within
a sample and in the slides.
ANDY BECK: Yeah, I
mean, you mean just
like a continuum
of aggressiveness.
Yeah, I think it is a continuum.
I mean, this is more
of a binary task,
but there's going
to be continuums
of grade within the cancer.
I mean, that's another
level of adding on.
If we wanted to correlate
this with outcome,
it would definitely be
valuable to do that.
To not just say quantitate
the bulk of tumor
but to estimate the malignancy
of every individual nucleus,
which we can do also.
So you can actually classify,
not just tumor region
but you can classify
individual cells.
And you can classify
them based on malignancy.
And then you can
get the, sort of,
gradient within a population.
In this study, it was just a
region-based, not a cell-based,
but you can definitely do
that, and definitely, it's
a spectrum.
I mean, it's kind of
like the atypia idea.
Everything in biology is
pretty much on a spectrum,
like from normal to atypical
to low-grade cancer,
medium-grade cancer,
high-grade cancer,
and these sorts of
methods do allow
you to really more
precisely estimate
where you are on that continuum.
And that's the basic approach.
We get the big
whole site images.
We figure out how
to sample patches
from the different regions
to optimize performance
of the model during
training time.
And then during
testing time, just we
take a whole big
whole site image.
We break it into millions
of little patches.
Send each patch individually.
We don't actually--
you could potentially
use spatial information
about how close they
are to each other,
which would make
the process less efficient.
We don't do that.
We just send them
in individually
and then visualize the
output as a heat map.
And this, I think,
isn't in the reference
I sent so the one
I sent showed how
you were able to combine the
estimates of the deep learning
system with the human
pathologist's estimate
to make the human pathologist's
error rate go down by 85%
and get to less than 1%.
And the interesting thing about
how these systems keep getting
better over time and
potentially they over-fit
to the competition data set--
because I think we submitted,
maybe, three times,
which isn't that many.
But over the course of six
months after the first closing
of the competition, people kept
competing and making systems
better.
And actually, the
fully automated system
on this data set achieved an
error rate of less than 1%
by the final submission date,
which was significantly better
than both the pathologists
in the competition, which
is the error rate, I believe,
cited in the initial archive
paper.
And also, they took
the same set of slides
and sent them out to
pathologists operating
in clinical practice, where
they had really significantly
higher error rates,
mainly due to the fact,
they were more constrained
by time limitations
in clinical practice
than in the competition.
And most of the errors they
are making are false negatives.
Simply, they don't
have the time to focus
on small regions of metastasis
amid these humongous giga
pixel-size slides.
AUDIENCE: In the paper, you
say you combined the machine
learning options with
the pathologists,
but you don't really say how.
Is that it that they
look at the heat maps,
or is it just sort of combined?
ANDY BECK: Yeah, no,
it's a great question.
So today, we do it that way.
And that's the way
in clinical practice
we're building it, that the
pathologists will look at both
and then make a diagnosis
based on incorporating both.
For the competition,
it was very simple,
and the organizers
actually did it.
They interpreted
them independently.
So the pathologists just
looked at all the slides.
Our system made a prediction.
It was literally the
average of the probability
that that slide
contained cancer.
That became the final
score, and then the AUC
went to 99% from
whatever it was,
92% by combining
these two scores.
AUDIENCE: I guess they
make uncorrelated errors.
ANDY BECK: Exactly.
They're pretty
much uncorrelated,
particularly because
the pathologists tend
to have almost all
false negatives,
and the deep
learning system tends
to be fooled by a few
things, like artefact.
And they do make
uncorrelated errors,
and that's why there's a
huge bump in performance.
So I kind of made a
reference to this,
but any of these
competition data sets
are relatively easy
to get really good at.
People have shown
that you can actually
build models that just predict
a data set using deep learning.
Like, deep learning
is almost too good
at finding certain patterns
and can find artefact.
So it's just a caveat
to keep in mind.
We're doing experiments on
lots of real-world testing
of methods like this
across many labs
with many different standing
procedures and tissue
preparation
procedures, et cetera,
to evaluate the robustness.
But that's why competition
results, even ImageNet always
need to be taken
with a grain of salt.
And then but we sort
of think the value add
of this is going to be huge.
I mean, it's hard to tell
because it's such a big image,
but this is what a
pathologist today is
looking at under a
microscope, and it's
very hard to see anything.
And with a very simple
visualization, just of
the output of the AI system as
red where cancer looks like it
is.
It's clearly a sort of
great map of the areas
they need to be
sure to focus on.
And this is real data
from this example, where
this bright red area, in fact,
contains this tiny little rim
of metastatic
breast cancer cells
that would be very easy to miss
without that assistant sort
of just pointing you in
the right place to look at,
because it's a tiny
set of 20 cells
amid a big sea of all
these normal lymphocytes.
And here's another
one that, again,
now you can see from low power.
It's like a satellite
image or something,
where you can focus immediately
on this little red area, that,
again, is a tiny pocket
of 10 cancer cells
amid hundreds of thousands
of normal cells that are now
visible from low power.
So this is one application
we're working on,
where the clinical
use case will be
today, people are just
sort of looking at images
without the assistance
of any machine learning.
And they just have to kind
of pick a number of patches
to focus on with no guidance.
So sometimes they focus
on the right patches,
sometimes they don't, but
clearly they don't have time
to look at all of this
at high magnification,
because that would
take an entire day
if you were trying to
look at 40X magnification
at the whole image.
So they sort of use
their intuition to focus.
And for that
reason, they end up,
as we've seen, making
significant number of mistakes.
It's not reproducible,
because people
focus on different
aspects of the image,
and it's pretty slow.
And they're faced with
this empty report.
So they have to actually
summarize everything
they've looked at in a report.
Like, what's the diagnosis?
What's the size?
So let's say there's cancer
here and cancer here, they
have to manually add the
distances of the cancer
in those two regions.
And then they have to put this
into a staging system that
incorporates how many areas
of metastasis there are
and how big are they?
And all of these things are
pretty much automatable.
And this is the
kind of thing we're
building, where the system will
highlight where it sees cancer,
tell the pathologist
to focus there.
And then based on the
input of the AI system
and the input of the pathologist
can summarize all of that data,
quantitative as
well as diagnostic
as well as summary staging.
Sort of if the pathologist
then takes this
is their first
version of the report,
they can edit it,
confirm it, sign it out.
That data goes back
into the system, which
can be used for more
training data in the future
and the case is signed out.
So it's much faster, much more
accurate, and standardized
once this thing is fully
developed, which it isn't yet.
So this is a great
application for AI,
because you really do need--
you actually do
have a ton of data,
so you need to do an
exhaustive analysis that
has a lot of value.
It's a task where the local
image data in a patch,
which is really what
this current generation
of deep CNN's are really
good at, is enough.
So we're looking at things
at the cellular level.
Radiology actually
could be harder,
because you often want to
summarize over larger areas.
Here, you really often have
the salient information
in patches that really are
scalable in current ML systems.
And then we can interpret
the output to the model.
So it really isn't-- even though
the model itself is a black
box, we can visualize the
output on top of the image,
which gives us incredible
advantage in terms
of interpretability of what
the models are doing well,
what they're doing poorly on.
And it's a specialty,
pathology, where sort of 80%
is not good enough.
We want to get as close
to 100% as possible.
And that's one sort of
diagnostic application.
The last, or one of the last
examples I'm going to give
has to do with precision
immunotherapy, where we're not
only trying to identify
what the diagnosis is but
to actually subtype patients
to predict the right treatment.
And as I mentioned
earlier, immunotherapy
is a really important and
exciting, relatively new area
of cancer therapy,
which was another one
of the big advances in 2012.
Around the same time that
deep learning came out,
the first studies
came out showing
that targeting a protein
mostly on tumor cells
but also on immune cells, the
PD-1 or the PD-L1 protein,
which the protein's
job when it's on
is to inhibit immune response.
But in the setting of
cancer, the inhibition
of immune response is
actually bad for the patient,
because the immune system's
job is to really try
to fight off the cancer.
So they realized a very
simple therapeutic strategy
just having an antibody that
binds to this inhibitory signal
can sort of unleash the
patient's own immune system
to really end up curing really
serious advanced cancers.
And that image on
the top right sort of
speaks to that, where
this patient had
a very large melanoma.
And then they just got
this antibody to target,
to sort of invigorate
their immune system,
and then the tumor
really shrunk.
And one of the big biomarkers
for assessing which patients
will benefit from
these therapies
is the tumor cell or the
immune cell expressing
this drug target PD-1 or PD-L1.
And the one they
test for is PD-L1,
which is the ligand
for the PD-1 receptor.
So this is often the
key piece of data
used to decide who
gets these therapies.
And it turns out, pathologists
are pretty bad at scoring this,
not surprisingly, because
it's very difficult,
and there's millions of
cells potentially per case.
And they show an
interobserver agreement
of only 0.86 for scoring
on tumor cells, which
isn't bad, but 0.2 for scoring
it on immune cells, which
is super important.
So this is a drug target.
We're trying to measure to
see which patients might get
this life-saving therapy,
but the diagnostic we have
is super hard to interpret.
And some studies,
for this reason,
have shown sort of mixed results
about how valuable it is.
In some cases, it
appears valuable.
In other cases, it
appears it's not.
So we want to see would this
be a good example of where
we can use machine learning?
And for this type
of application,
this is really hard,
and we want to be
able to apply it across
not just one cancer but 20
different cancers.
So we built a system at
PathAI for generating lots
of training data at scale.
And that's something that a
competition just won't get you.
Like that competition
example had 300 slides.
Once a year, they do it.
But we want to be able to
build these models every week
or something.
So now, we have something
500 pathologists signed
into our system that we can use
to label lots of pathology data
for us and to really build
these models quickly and really
high quality.
So now we have something
like over 2 and 1/2 million
annotations in the system.
And that allows us to
build tissue region models.
And this is immunohistochemistry
in a cancer, where
we've trained a
model to identify
all of the cancer epithelium
in red, the cancer stroma
in green.
So now we know
where the protein is
being expressed, in the
epithelium or in the stroma.
And then we've also trained
cellular classification.
So now, for every single cell,
we classify it as a cell type.
Is it a cancer cell or a
fibroblast or a macrophage
or a lymphocyte?
And is it expressing
the protein,
based on how brown it is?
So while pathologists will
try to make some estimate
across the whole slide, we can
actually compute for every cell
and then compute
exact statistics
about which cells are
expressing this protein
and which patients might be the
best candidates for therapy.
And then the question is, can
we identify additional things
beyond just PD-L1 protein
expression that's predictive
of response to immunotherapy?
And we've developed some
machine learning approaches
for doing that.
And part of it's doing
things like quantitating
different cells and
regions on H and E
images, which
currently aren't used
at all in patient subtyping.
But we can do analyses to
extract new features here
and to ask, even
though nothing's
known about these images
and immunotherapy response,
can we discover
new features here?
And this would be
an example routinely
of the types of features
we can quantify now
using deep learning to extract
these features on any case.
And this is sort of like
every sort of pathologic
characteristic you
can sort of imagine.
And then we correlate
these with drug response
and can use this
as a discovery tool
for identifying new aspects
of pathology predictive
of which patients
will respond best.
And then we can combine
these features into models.
This is sort of a
ridiculous example
because they're so different.
But this would be
one example where
the output of the model, and
this is totally fake data
but I think it's just
to get to the point.
Is here, the color
indicates the treatment,
where green would be
the immunotherapy,
red would be the
traditional therapy,
and the goal is to
build a model to predict
which patients actually
benefit from the therapy.
So this may be an easy
question, but what
do you think, if
the model's working,
what would the title of
the graph on the right
be versus the graph on
the left if these are
the ways of classifying
patients with our model,
and the classifications
are going to be responder
class or non-responder class?
And the color
indicates the drug.
AUDIENCE: The drug works
or it doesn't work.
ANDY BECK: That's right but
what's the output of the model?
But you're right.
The interpretation of
these graphs is drug works,
drug doesn't work.
It's kind of a tricky
question, right?
But what is our model
trying to predict?
AUDIENCE: Whether the person
is going to die or not?
It looks like
likelihood of death
is just not as
high on the right.
ANDY BECK: I think
the overall likelihood
is the same on the two
graphs, right versus left.
You don't know how many
patients are in each arm.
But I think the
one piece on it--
so green is
experimental treatment.
Red is conventional treatment.
Maybe I already said that.
So here, and it's sort of like
a read my mind type question,
but here the output
of the model would
be responder to the drug would
be the right class of patients.
And the left class
of patients would
be non-responder to the drug.
So you're not actually saying
anything about prognosis,
but you're saying
that I'm predicting
that if you're in the right
population of patients,
you will benefit
from the blue drug.
And then you actually see
that on this right population
of patients, the blue
drug does really well.
And then the red
drug are patients
who we thought-- we predicted
would benefit from the drug,
but because it's
an experiment, we
didn't give them the right drug.
And in fact, they did
a whole lot worse.
Whereas, the one on
the left, we're saying
you don't benefit from
the drug, and they truly
don't benefit from the drug.
So this is the way of
using an output of a model
to predict drug response
and then visualizing
whether it actually works.
And it's kind of
like the example
I talked about before, but
here's a real version of it.
And you can learn this
directly using machine learning
to try to say, I want to
find patients who actually
benefit the most from a drug.
And then in terms of
how do we validate
our models are correct?
I mean, we have
two different ways.
One is do stuff like that.
So we build a model that
says, respond to drug,
don't respond to a drug.
And then we plot the
Kaplan-Meier curves.
If it's image analysis stuff, we
ask pathologists to hand label.
Many cells, and we
take the consensus
of pathologists as our ground
truth and go from there.
AUDIENCE: The way
you're presenting it,
it makes it sound like
all the data comes
from the pathology images.
But in reality, people look at
single nucleotide polymorphisms
or gene sequences or all kinds
of clinical data as well.
So how do you get those?
ANDY BECK: Yeah, I mean, the
beauty of the pathology data
is it's always available.
So that's why a lot
of the stuff we do
is focused on that, because
every clinical trial
patient has treatment
data, outcome
data, and pathology images.
So it's like, we can really
do this at scale pretty fast.
A lot of the other stuff is
things like gene expression,
many people are collecting them.
And it's important to
compare these to baselines
or to integrate them.
I mean, two things-- one is
compare to it as a baseline.
What can we predict in terms of
responder, non-responder using
just the pathology images versus
using just gene expression
data versus combining them?
And that would just be
increasing the input feature
space.
Part of the input feature
space comes from the images.
Part of it comes from
gene expression data.
Then you use machine
learning to focus
on the most important
characteristics
and predict outcome.
And the other is if you
want to sort of prioritize.
Use pathology as a
baseline because it's
available on everyone.
But then an adjuvant test
that costs another $1,000
and might take another
two weeks, how much does
that add to the prediction?
And that would be another way.
So I think it is
important, but a lot
of our technology to
developing our platform
is focused around how do
we most effectively use
pathology and can certainly
add in gene expression date.
I'm actually going to
talk about that next-- one
way of doing it.
Because it's a very natural
synergy, because they
tell you very different things.
So here's one example of
integrating, just kind
of relative to that question,
gene expression data
with image data, where the
cancer genome analysis,
and this is all public.
So they have pathology images,
RNA data, clinical outcomes.
They don't have the
greatest treatment data,
but it's a great place
for method development
for sort of ML in
cancer, including
pathology-type analyses.
So this is a case of melanoma.
We've trained a model to
identify cancer and stroma
and all the different cells.
And then we extract, as you saw,
sort of hundreds of features.
And then we can rank
the features here
by their correlation
with survival.
So now we're mapping
from pathology images
to outcome data and we find just
in a totally data-driven way
that there's some small set
of 15 features or so highly
associated with survival.
The rest aren't.
And the top ranking one
is an immune cell feature,
increased area of
stroma plasma cells
that are associated
with increased survival.
And this was an analysis
that was really just linking
the images with outcome.
And then we can ask, well,
what are the genes underlying
this pathology?
So pathology is telling you
about cells and tissues.
RNAs are telling you about
the actual transcriptional
landscape of what's
going on underneath.
And then we can rank all
the genes in the genome
just by their correlation with
this quantitative phenotype
we're measuring on
the pathology images.
And here are all the genes,
ranked from 0 to 20,000.
And again, we see a small
set that we're thresholding
at a correlation
of 0.4, strongly
associated with the pathologic
phenotype we're measuring.
And then we sort of
discover these sets
of genes that are known to be
highly enriched in immune cell
genes.
Sort of which is some
form of validation
that we're measuring what
we think we're measuring,
but also this sets of genes are
potentially new drug targets,
new diagnostics, et
cetera, that was uncovered
by going from clinical
outcomes to pathology data
to the underlying RNA signature.
And then kind of the beauty of
the approach we're working on
is it's super scalable,
and in theory, you
could apply it to all of
TCGA or other data sets
and apply it across cancer
types and do things like find--
automatically find artefacts
in all of the slides
and kind of do this
in a broad way.
And then sort of the most
interesting part, potentially,
is analyzing the
outputs of the models
and how they
correlate with things
like drug response or
underlying molecular profiles.
And this is really the
process we're working on,
is how do we go from images to
new ways of measuring disease
pathology?
And kind of in summary, a lot
of the technology development
that I think is
most important today
for getting ML to
work really well
in the real world for
applications in medicine
is a lot about being super
thoughtful about building
the right training data set.
And how do you do that in
a scalable way and even
in a way that incorporates
machine learning?
Which is kind of what
I was talking about
before-- intelligently
picking patches.
But that sort of concept
applies everywhere.
So I think there's almost
more room for innovation
on the defining the
training data set side
than on the predictive
modeling side,
and then putting
the two together
is incredibly important.
And for the kind of
work we're doing,
there's already such great
advances in image processing.
A lot of it's about
engineering and scalability,
as well as rigorous validation.
And then how do we connect it
with underlying molecular data
as well as clinical
outcome data?
Versus trying to solve a lot
of the core vision tasks, which
there's already just
been incredible progress
over the past couple of years.
And in terms of in
our world, things
we think a lot about,
not just the technology
and putting together
our data sets but also,
how do we work with regulators?
How do we make
strong business cases
for partners working
with to actually change
what they're doing
to incorporate some
of these new approaches that
will really bring benefits
to patients around quality and
accuracy in their diagnosis?
So in summary--
I know you have to
go in four minutes--
this has been a
longstanding problem.
There's nothing new
about trying to apply AI
to diagnostics or
to vision tasks,
but there are some really big
differences in the past five
years that, even
in my short career,
I've seen a sea
change in this field.
One is availability
of digital data--
it's now much cheaper to
generate lots of images
at scale.
But even more
important, I think,
are the last two, which is
access to large-scale computing
resources is a game-changer
for anyone with access
to cloud computing or
large computing resources.
Just, we all have access
to a sort of arbitrary
compute today, and
10 years ago, that
was a huge limitation
in this field.
As well as these really
major algorithmic advances,
particularly deep
CNN's revision.
And, in general, AI
works extremely well
when problems can be defined to
get the right type of training
data, access,
large-scale computing,
as well as implement things
like deep CNNs that work really
well.
And it sort of fails
everywhere else, which
is probably 98% of things.
But if you can create a problem
where the algorithms actually
work, you can have lots
of data to train on,
they can succeed really well.
And this sort of vision-based
AI-powered pathology
is broadly applicable across,
really, all image-based tasks
and pathology.
It does enable
integration with things
like omics data--
genomics, transcriptonics,
SNP data, et cetera.
And in the near future, we
think this will be incorporated
into clinical practice.
And even today, it's
really central to a lot
of research efforts.
And I just want
to end on a quote
from 1987, where
in the future, AI
can be expected to become
staples of pathology practice.
And I think we're much, much
closer than 30 years ago.
And I want to thank
everyone at PathAI,
as well as Hunter, who
really helped put together
a lot of these slides.
And we do have lots
of opportunities
for machine learning
engineers, software engineers,
et cetera, at PathAI.
So certainly reach out if you're
interested in learning more.
And I'm happy to take any
questions, if we have time.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Yes, I think generally
very aggressive events.
I was wondering how close is
this to clinical practice?
Is there FDA or--
ANDY BECK: Yeah, so I mean,
actual clinical practice,
probably 2020, like
early, mid-2020.
But I mean, today, it's very
active in clinical research,
so like clinical trials,
et cetera, that do
involve patients, but it's in a
much more well-defined setting.
But the first
clinical use cases,
at least of the types
of stuff we're building,
will be, I think,
about a year from now.
And I think it will
start small and then
get progressively bigger.
So I don't think it's
going to be everything
all at once transforms
in the clinic,
but I do think
we'll start seeing
the first applications out.
And they will go-- some of
them will go through the FDA,
and there'll be some
laboratory-developed tests.
Ours will go through the
FDA, but labs themselves
can actually validate
tools themselves.
And that's another path.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ANDY BECK: Sure.
PROFESSOR: So have you been
using observational data sets?
You gave one example where
you tried to use data
from a randomized controlled
trial, or both trials,
you used different
randomized control trials
for different efficacies
of each event.
The next major segment
of this course,
starting in about two weeks,
will be about causal inference
from observational data.
I'm wondering if
that is something
PathAI has gotten into yet?
And if so, what has your
finding been so far?
ANDY BECK: So we have focused
a lot on randomized controlled
trial data and have
developed methods
around that, which sort
of simplifies the problem
and allows us to do, I think,
pretty clever things around how
to generate those types
of graphs I was showing,
where you truly can infer the
treatment is having an effect.
And we've done far less.
I'm super interested in that.
I'd say the
advantages of RCTs are
people are already investing
hugely in building these very
well-curated data sets
that include images,
molecular data, when available,
treatment, and outcome.
And it's just that's
there, because they've
invested in the clinical trial.
They've invested in
generating that data set.
To me, the big challenge
in observational stuff,
there's a few but I'd be
interested in what you guys are
doing and learn
about it, is getting
the data is not easy, right?
The outcome data is not--
linking the pathology
images with the outcome data
even is, actually,
in my opinion,
harder in observational
way than in RCT.
Because they're actually
doing it and paying for it
and collecting it in RCTs.
No one's really done
a very good job of--
TCGA would be a good place to
play around with because that
is observational data.
And we want to
also, we generally
want to focus on
actionable decisions.
And RCT is sort of
perfectly set up for that.
Do I give drug X or not?
So I think if you put
together the right data set
and somehow make the
results actionable,
it could be really,
really useful,
because there is a lot of data.
But I think just
collecting the outcomes
and linking them with images
is actually quite hard.
And ironically, I think it's
harder for observational
than for randomized control
trials, where they're already
collecting it.
I guess one example would
be the Nurses' Health
Study or these big epidemiology
cohorts, potentially.
They are collecting that
data and organizing it.
But what were you
thinking about?
Do you have anything
with pathology
in mind for causal inference
from observational data?
PROFESSOR: Well, I
think, the example
you gave, like Nurses' Health
Study or the Framingham study,
where you're tracking
patients across time.
They're getting different
interventions across time.
And because of the way the
study was designed, in fact,
there are even good outcomes
for patients across times.
So that problem
in the profession
doesn't happen there.
But then suppose you were
to take it from a biobank
and do pathologies?
You're now getting the samples.
Then, you can ask
about, well, what
is the effect of different
interventions or treatment
plans on outcomes?
The challenge, of course,
drawing inferences
there is that there
was bias in terms
of who got what treatments.
That's where the techniques
that we talk about in class
would become very important.
I just say, I appreciate the
challenges that you mentioned.
ANDY BECK: I think it's
incredibly powerful.
I think the other issue I just
think about is that treatments
change so quickly over time.
So you don't want to be like
overfitting to the past.
But I think there's
certain cases where
the therapeutic decisions
today are similar to what
they were in the past.
There are other areas, like
immunooncology, where there's
just no history to learn from.
So I think it depends on the--
PROFESSOR: All right, then with
that, let's thank Andy Beck.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY BECK: Thank you.